with over 30 years of life coaching
experience Tony Robbins is the go-to guy
if you want to make a change in your
life that you believe is unchangeable
he's changed the lives of thousands of
people all around the world if you want
to learn how to deal with your stress
and depression you need to at least give
Tony Robbins a shot mentor me Tony
overwhelmed you got to first own the
fact that you've identified that as the
way that you live you actually I always
tell people you get what you tolerate
and so you've gotten used to tolerating
that and you start thinking this is me
when all it is is a habit it's a habit
of the way of looking at life that's a
habit and I'll use your body it's a
habit of language that you use coz
certain words when you use them you
become them I really believe what you've
got to do is train yourself train
yourself physically it's like working
out you know people say don't you have
bad days of course I get pissed off I
get frustrated I feel sad adults things
but I don't stay there I used to live
there I used to be depressed all the
time I'd never get depressed now because
my cuz I'm so positive not it's not fake
it's like a muscle you know you can
train yourself to get frustrated by
doing hold on you can train yourself to
be stressed out you train yourself to
feel sad by doing it so often we get
wired the more we do something more
wired we go you can train yourself to
feel passionate you can train yourself
to feel strong and I tell people don't
settle remember you get what you
tolerate put yourself in gear go for a
workout start to train your body in your
mind and also find something you want to
serve greater than yourself because if
you're just doing this for you you're
going to probably have bad days but if
you're doing for your family if you're
doing it for your community if you're
doing it for Humanity you really aren't
it isn't [ __ ] you're gonna find a
level of energy inside you you're gonna
get insights you never have I really
believe motive does matter if your
motives just for yourself you don't get
much insight life supports you because
you're part of life but if you're trying
to support more than yourself when you
get a vision that's our businesses grow
that's how movements happen right find
something bigger yourself to serve and
make sure that you don't tolerate
weakness in yourself that doesn't mean
you're not to feel sad but you're not
just going to stay there because you
made that decision life's too short to
feel like crap
I've decided I want to live in a
beautiful state for the rest of my life
that doesn't mean I won't feel bad it
means I won't stay there because I'm in
control and I can't change it so can you
the breakthrough happens by conditioning
your mind every day by feeding it a role
model or story it's putting yourself in
a pink state when you follow through by
getting physically strong it's creating
a little ritual of doing a little bit
each day and then you get momentum but
the most important thing of all is what
we start out with why absolutely why is
it a must for you it doesn't have to be
here against the wall but it has to be
something you're hungry for because the
only difference in people is hunger and
if you're not hungry get around people
that are hungry and something will hit
you you watch a conversation get around
people are doing better and all of a
sudden you start going
my wife sucks I remember I went to a guy
in LA it's one of the most
multi-billionaire guys I'll never forget
and I lived in the Del Mar Castle and I
was really proud that was like the
symbol of me having taken myself from
being poor to providing for my family
this great place building castles in
Europe overlooking the ocean not far
from you and I went this guy's house
he's billionaire he took me down to his
wine cellar I don't even bring one went
through this whole thing at the end of
the night I was depressed I lived in the
Del Mar tenement as far as I was
concerned I really was I was like I live
in a crappy place and all my standards
changed all sudden I wasn't a little
settled for living that all of a sudden
my back was to the ball in a different
way because as a man I knew was capable
of more so people can change their
standard by getting around where it's
better people can change their standard
by getting associated what's true like
the bills they got to solve the problems
they got to do it or they can do it
because they're excited because it's
something new they want to take on
everyone's different but they got to
find the Y and they got to come up with
some daily rituals to get them going and
just do a step at a time that's where
you get momentum that's what a
five-point plan anyone can follow to get
over stress and trauma in their lives
totally through it well I think it first
of all I maquon think clear the quality
of your life is the quality of where you
live emotionally but we all have a home
angry people try to find a way to get
angry even if their life doesn't they be
angry about we can always find it sad
people find what have you said caring
people find a way to care for other
people so one thing that I identify is
where are you living what's your home
what's your habit and then the way to
change it is when I was homeless
literally on my own just getting started
I didn't have
the Internet but I decided I had to go
to a library and I had to feed my mind I
always tell people the first stages you
know weeds grow automatically one of my
teachers taught me is that every day
stand guarded the door of your mind and
feed it something good because if your
worst enemy puts sugar in your coffee
here you're fine if your best friend by
accident trying to help you put some
strychnine you're dead so if you feed
your mind every day thirty minutes a day
of reading something hearing something
second you got to strengthen your body
and the reason Peirce is fear is
physical right so is stagnation
so is numbness so a sadness such so is
rage and when you go in and change your
body by an intense workout or a run or
even intense walk and the Bloods flowing
through you science has shown it
instantly changes your biochemistry now
your mind by you're working together
third thing all these people did in
common if you watch they found a mission
bigger than themselves something that
they want to aspire to that was worth
more than their pain and then the fourth
thing is you got to find a role model
you know you heard it in with Nick
almost anybody finds a role model that
makes it real I was with Warren Buffett
and with Sara Blakely the youngest
billionaire we did this roundtable about
the future and we listened this woman
and when women meet her they don't just
love Spanx or product but made her
billionaire they love this woman because
she's a role model what's possible you
get a role model it becomes real to you
if you get a plan you get a gold plan
and you take massive action and the last
step number five there's always somebody
all are soft than you are I don't care
what you've done so if you can go help
somebody worse off you put your life in
perspective and it also reminds you
life's not about me it's about we I
always tell people the secret to a great
life the secret to living is giving and
there's when you realize there's
something you still to give even if you
lost your legs even if you've been
through a horrific financial situation
your life can improve but more
importantly you'll have a meaningful
life because your life will contribute
to other people if you think about the
first thing that determines whether you
can do something or not and I put that
in this first box at the top here on the
left side it's potential like what's the
potential of the MA like when you guys
started you proved something no one had
done in history you ran the four-minute
mile right for Godley knows how many
centuries they're trying to run a
four-minute mile Roger Bannister does it
how did he do it do you remember you did
it in this industry right you made a
million bucks in a day no one had ever
done that in history right after you did
it a bunch of the guys were doing it the
case became possible Roger Bannister did
just go physically practice he made a
shift in his hat he practiced in his
head because he could never achieve it
physically so he had a change in his
head first so the result became certain
enough he believed it and his body got
him through after roger bannister in
that four-minute mile within two years
37 people ran a four-minute mile when no
one in history ever done here's how it
works
the potential for anybody getting your
product is extraordinary they could do
what you've done is much more or less
they can do whatever they want to do the
potentials their markets proven that
whether or not they tap enough potential
has a lot to deal with what action they
take which is a question of King to me
with right like you know copy owns
potential to not taking action and we
all know that the action that dag is
going to determine the results they get
that's pretty obvious so most people
have a belief about what their real
potential is no matter what you tell
them and that affects how much action
they take and of course that affects the
result and then ironically that result
reinforces their belief and then that
belief effects it so I'll give an
example let's say a person has unlimited
potential we all agree but they take
little action little results why because
they have to start with a problem with
their belief they don't believe it's
really going to happen for me maybe for
Frank Kearns because it got the cool
hair and stuff or maybe it's for you
because you're so driven but it's not me
maybe Tony Robbins because she's a freak
out these big teeth whatever their
thought process is right they got this
big right but what happens is if you
believe that there's very little
potential how much action you're gonna
take profit little and when you take
little potential with a little action
what kind of results you get lousy
little results and we need a little
results what does that do to your belief
you go see I told you this was a waste
of time soldier this wouldn't work and
then what happens you tap even less
potential to take even less action even
the worst results and your belief gets
even weaker and this sucker feeds on
itself until you are in a downward
spiral poisonous it's poisonous in its
self-fulfilling now what if something
could happen that could come along and
fill you with a sense of absolute
certainty not like I believe but mean
well you know and you guys this case
mine as well we knew because we had to
because we burned the boats there was no
other option we had to find a way we had
we were going to live that way
we all did it in different ways and for
different reasons but in essence that
was it if you get yourself in a state of
certainty that this is gonna work I'm
gonna find the way and if this is work I
will make the way then you tap a lot
more potential and when you're certain
when your potential you take massive
action when you take massive action you
really believe in something you get
great results when you get great results
your brain goes see I told you I was a
stud I told you this thing would work
out now you even stronger you tap more
potential take greater action bigger
results that's how you went from 300
bucks in a week to 2500 five days to a
hundred thousand and a month to a
million bucks in a day same thing with
you and we get momentum so why the rich
get richer the poor get poorer now some
people go out and go well I'm gonna take
a bunch of action alright I'm gonna open
this product mentor try it
they'll say to you I even did it but
it's like a Salesman who goes and knocks
on the door he knocks on 100 doors and
says exactly right and even if it
doesn't say verbally his face says it
because he doesn't believe it's going to
work
so his voice his body the execution is
so weak maybe if he talks a hundred
people somebody's gonna buy out of pity
they don't when his kids the scarve
right but he's not going to get the
result so the core difference in people
is how do you produce certain day when
the world isn't giving it to you you go
out and try and you're trying your case
you're a hundred thousand a debt
nothing's working how do you keep
yourself going the way you did it the
way I did it the way you're doing it we
may not done it consciously is we didn't
change our potential that was there and
it wasn't even taking more action taking
more action with beliefs not going to
works not going to change anything we
got results in our head that made us
feel certain as if it had already
happened what do I do when I feel the
fear paralysis that happens when my mind
starts to run wild it seems like there
is a cascade of doom and gloom thoughts
and I can't seem to take any action I
just worry you know people who are not
used to having that emotion or having it
these days we've all had it at different
times of our lives we just forget and I
think what he has to do is what's the
time of your life that you had an
enormous crisis but what pulled you
through again we have people go through
on that side answer five questions and
what it basically does is help you
figure out where was this crisis before
you've even forgotten about
what told you through what belief what
strategy what experience who helped you
what triggered you and then what did you
do that made that shift but I also say
remember one affirmation if you would in
your mind and your body own the fact
that money is not your life this is just
money I mean when I was told I had a
tumor in my brain
later on years later when I thought I
might lose my wife to cancer I didn't
tell you something money doesn't matter
at all but when we get focused on what
matters most were there so I mentioned
earlier getting physical is really
important cuz there's the physical
things around you think about it not
just exercise going for an intense run
lifting weights something that pumps the
blood and oxygen through you because
when you do that your entire psychology
changes you see the world's your
different place so I'd say it's contrast
of other people's great stories model
the best that's in you what have you
been through these things before you've
been resilient if you're honest with
yourself and get totally physical and
make that a ritual for you and then
you'll start to look for role models out
of turn things around can I had one yes
boys people I love people just you know
and embrace embrace human beings who are
all around you and make sure that you're
good friends that they can be a good
friend eat and you'll feel better I
think it the most important thing you do
is get outside yourself if you want to
help somebody else we have a basket
brigade we feed three million people
here at Thanksgiving from all over the
world it's because somebody fed my
family when you won't help somebody else
you realize you have no problem you
realize how you might feel like you have
something to give and we all need
meaning in our life we don't want to
just get the life now is about what can
you give that's what a light job thank
you guys so much for watching the point
of the mentor me series is to spend a
little bit more quality time with people
who've achieved massive success and
hopefully a little bit of how they think
rubs off on us so I hope you enjoyed
this video I'd love to know what your
take is on stress and depression what
you thought up Tony views as well leave
in the comments below I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon